parece una Floresta casi virgen pero se
trata de un bosque reforestado
incrustado en la segunda ciudad más
poblada de Brasil este Parque Nacional
fue ideado en el siglo XIX por el
emperador Pedro segundo preocupado por
la falta de agua en Río de Janeiro
décadas de cultivo intensivo del café
acabaron con la mata atlántica la
vegetación original de la región y
secaron los manantiales para esta
arquitecta fue una estrategia acertada
fue extremadamente importante además La
Floresta de tijuca propicia también un
clima más ameno en la ciudad ella
suavizó el calor que hacía en Río de
Janeiro
hoy es un rincón muy apreciado por los
turistas que visitan el Cristo Redentor
erguido en la montaña del corcovado
Isabel explica que Su riqueza no es solo
medioambiental en 2012 fue declarado
patrimonio mundial y cultural por la
UNESCO
el valor cultural del parque se debe
primero al hecho de haber sido una gran
área reforestada por el hombre además
hay varios puntos hermosos en el parque
que son verdaderamente atractivos Grutas
diques capillas antiguas haciendas de
café que fueron expropiadas y
convertidas en restaurantes
El desafío ahora es preservar esta
Floresta y mejorar su hábitat la
directora cuenta que hay un programa
para reintroducir animales como macacos
a guties y Tucanes
La Floresta de tijuca hoy demuestra
cuánto un área reforestada puede
contribuir con la vida del ser humano
por ejemplo con la producción del agua
hoy una parte de la ciudad Se abastece
gracias al agua que sale de este bosque
si no existiese el parque de tijuca
tendríamos otra realidad en esta ciudad
estas cascadas son la prueba viva de que
es posible recuperar entornos devastados
por el hombre